[Music]
you see my such an affable guy you got
into a bit of a tiff with Geraldo is
that right
me and her Aldo got into it a couple
weeks ago yeah you know he made that
comment about the hoodie regard the
Trayvon Martin case and you know there
was this kind of collective outrage yeah
yeah and so I went on my Twitter and I
just wrote you know it's appropriate to
say this any day but today especially
seriously you were Aldo and I said that
on Twitter right right right and then I
saw like news articles started kind of
quoting it and I read like this is like
a real headline this is a respectable
news outlet wrote this they wrote
Geraldo Rivera says Trayvon Martin's
hoodie made him a target receives major
backlash Fox News commentator says
Martin's killer should be prosecuted but
that the victims attire put him at fault
Aziz Ansari responds you Geraldo it's
kind of funny but it also makes me sound
like really dumb like the reporter was
like so what do you think about this or
Aldo comment you were all done
thank you another nuance yeah we've been
a bit better if you said let me think
about this for a night and then I'll
give you my response
now apologize but he's still Geraldo's
yeah yeah well you you let's talk about
you're doing something that is quite
interesting a lot of comedians over the
years of course they do stand-up
specials but this is a new trend
stand-up specials online yeah tell us a
little bit about that so basically my
stand-up special you just buy it on my
website
Aziz Ansari calm for five dollars and
you can download or stream it louis c.k
did a similar thing a few months ago and
everyone seemed to really like it so I
decided to do a similar thing and you
know when you do something like that we
just put it for download you know where
he is people might steal it so I tried
to reach out to that community like that
BitTorrent community and see if they
could help me and plant fake ones so
like you download what you think is my
special then you hit play and it's
something different right and this one
guy did me an amazing solid I tried to
find his name on Twitter I couldn't find
it but you'd go to this one site you
think you're downloading my special and
instead you get an episode of Baywatch
guest starring Geraldo Rivera the
character is something yeah do we I
think we have a clip of this infamous
episode of Baywatch where Geraldo is the
guest star let's take a look I love you
very much and I'm sorry that I wasn't
the one for you but your happiness is
the most important thing in the world
for me and I wish you the best of luck
you're getting a great guy
take care of her she's one of the night
and she's kidding one-in-a-million and
me I mean watched she settled for a
hamburger like you once you get that
steak he plays a nerd he literally plays
like a guy named like an Urkel
who's yeah pants up and is trying to get
have Mitch teach him how to get away
just trying to help him be cool I
watched that I was like I remember this
way too much this is so sad I remember
everything that happen in the episode
what's creepier is not three days ago
before I even knew this was happening
with you I was talking to Andy Richter
about that episode that exactly how does
that come up how would that ever come up
it's a commercial break and I was like
candy there was this one time where
Geraldo playing nerd welcome to inside
our lives that's absolutely true